im Atomkraftwerk Fukushima hat es heute
die dritte Explosion gegeben es war und
es ist kein leeres Wort wenn ich sage
wir können nicht einfach zur
Tagesordnung übergehen es gibt keine
Argumente außer rein ideologischen basta
Argumenten die Kernkraft nicht zu
verlängern zumindest zu lang diese Krise
überwunden ist deswegen lasst mich euch
etwas Mut machen denn seien wir ehrlich
niemand braucht die Atomenergie lassen
wir diesen Irrsinn bleiben wir bei
Atomkonsens weniges in Deutschland
erzeugt so viele Emotionen wie Atomkraft
nach Jahrzehnte langen Schlachten
brauchte es den Super-GAU in Fukushima
damit die Regierung den Atomausstieg
beschlossen das war damals der
endgültige Ausstieg nach einem
vorübergehenden wieder einstieg und
jetzt sorgt Russlands Angriffskrieg und
die Energieknappheit doch noch
übergangsweise für den Weiterbetrieb
über den eigentlichen ausstiegsmoment
hinaus
es ist einer aus der drohenden
energienot geborene Entscheidung und
dennoch wurde sie enorm emotional
ausgefochten wie im ganzen Land schon in
all den Jahrzehnten zuvor nach den
Schätzungen des Kieler Innenministeriums
hatten sich bis zum Mittag gut 30.000
Kernkraftgegner in der Wilstermarsch
eingefunden tausende weitere
Demonstranten waren im Verkehrschaos
stecken geblieben viele von ihnen
stießen erst im Laufe des Nachmittags zu
dem go der Demonstrierenden
jenseits aller Emotionen was spricht
eigentlich grundsätzlich für und was
spricht gegen die Atomkraft herzlich
willkommen
schauen wir uns das für und wieder in
zwei wichtigen Bereichen an zum einen
die Energiesicherheit und die Kosten und
zum anderen die Folgen für die Umwelt
beginnen wir mit der Energiesicherheit
und den Kosten im Moment beeinflusst
insbesondere Russland Krieg gegen die
Ukraine und die damit verbundene Gas
Knappheit die Stabilität des Stromnetzes
Expertinnen und Experten haben daher
untersucht wie sich eine verlängerte
Laufzeit der Atomkraftwerke auf das
Stromnetz auswirken würde das zeigt sich
es hat einen gewissen positiven Effekt
Atomstrom trägt also dazu bei mögliche
Strom Engpässe in diesem Winter
vermeiden zu helfen Punkt 2 die
Stromkosten ich glaube da der Winter
richtig hart wird also wir fangen
obwohl viele Stromkunden schon jetzt
beim auch sparen bleibt die berechtigte
Angst vor hohen Preisen und nicht wenige
haben längst massiv gestiegene
Rechnungen im Briefkasten und damit sind
wir bei einem weiteren Argument für
Atomkraft mehr Strom aus Atomkraftwerken
kann sinkende Strompreise bedeuten eine
aktuelle Studie des leibniz-instituts
für Wirtschaftsforschung zeigt
beispielsweise dass der Betrieb aller
drei Atomkraftwerke bis 2030 den
Strompreis in 2023 um rund 7% senken
würde der Grund dafür ist dass die
kostenintensivsten Kraftwerke die zur
Deckung des Strombedarfs benötigt werden
in den Tarif für alle anderen festlegen
derzeit sind es in der Regel die teuren
Gaskraftwerke durch Atomkraft aber singt
der Gasverbrauch und damit dann indirekt
auch der Strompreis auf der kontra-seite
aber stehen die enormen Kosten der
Atomkraftwerke
wir haben festgestellt dass
Atomkraftwerke sehr sehr teuer sind und
ohne Subventionen nicht frei am Markt
der bestehen können und es sind
wahnsinnig kostenintensiv laut Deutsche
Institut für Wirtschaftsforschung ist
die Investition in ein Atomkraftwerk
privatwirtschaftlich unrent haben mit
der aktuellen verfügbaren Technologie
beispielsweise wird ein neu gebautes
Standard AKW im Laufe seiner
Nutzungszeit zwischen eineinhalb und
knapp 9 Milliarden Euro Verlust einfach
und damit werden wir beim zweiten
wichtigen Thema bei dem wir uns für und
wieder ansehen sollten die Folgen der
Atomkraft für die Umwelt ich denke gegen
die Atomkraft gibt es weltweite größten
Vorurteile und gleichzeitig ist sie die
wichtigste Technologie für den
Umweltschutz das Argument wird
Atomkraftgegnern vermutlich einen Stich
versetzen aber Atomkraft ist
klimafreundlich sie verursacht deutlich
weniger klimaschädliche Emissionen als
Kohle oder Erdgas was wir derzeit in
Deutschland machen ist dass wir meiner
Meinung nach mutwillig und überstürzt
pro Jahr auf Kernenergie demnächst
verzichten die CO2-frei ist und
stattdessen aber Braunkohle weiterlaufen
lassen und massiv Gaskraftwerke dazu
bauen und das ist angesichts der Klima
Frage ist das eigentlich
unverantwortlich und noch ein weiteres
Argument für die Atomkraft verschiedene
Studien kommen zu dem Ergebnis dass die
Luft Verschmutzung die bei der
Stromerzeugung durch fossile
Energiequellen entsteht viele Menschen
das Leben kostet ganz kleine Teilchen
werden leider ins Blut transportiert das
führt zu Atemwegserkrankungen und
Erfolge zu Herz-Kreislauf-Erkrankungen
und in der Folge kann es sein dass ein
kleiner Teil der Bevölkerung dadurch
eben chronische Krankheiten erwirbt der
Atomkraft wiederum kaum Luft
Verschmutzung verursacht weiß sie in
diesem Punkt eine wesentlich bessere
Bilanz auf der anderen Seite hat die
Vergangenheit gezeigt was passieren kann
wenn ein Atomkraftwerk außer Kontrolle
gerät
1986 kommt es in Tschernobyl zur
Katastrophe im Rahmen von
Wartungsarbeiten explodiert ein Reaktor
radioaktive Stoffe gelangen in die
Atmosphäre der Wind verteilt sie über
Europa durch den Super-GAU von
Tschernobyl starben nach offiziellen
Angaben 32 Menschen nach
wissenschaftlichen Schätzungen waren es
allein bis hier zwischen 7 und 10.000
im Atomkraftwerk Fukushima hat es heute
die dritte Explosion gegeben später
folgte ein Brand im Reaktor 4 auch die
innere Hülle von Reaktor 2 ist
beschädigt Japans Atomkatastrophe hat
die Dimension von Tschernobyl fast
erreicht
anlass genug für Angela Merkel sich
schnell und kompromisslos an die Spitze
der zunehmenden mehr als Meinung zu
setzen es war und es ist kein leeres
Wort wenn ich sage wir können nicht
einfach zur Tagesordnung übergehen kurz
darauf beschloss die schwarz-gelbe
Regierung den Atomausstieg ein weiteres
Argument gegen Atomkraft ist die Gefahr
des kommerziell genutzte Atomkraftwerke
zum Ziel von Angriffen werden eine
Bedrohung die in den Zeiten des Kriegs
in der Ukraine nicht mehr nur
hypothetisch ist das Atomkraftwerk
saporicia steht unter russischem
Beschuss der ukrainische Präsident
spricht von Terror wir haben eine Nacht
durchgestanden die das Ende der
Geschichte hätte sein können der
Geschichte der Ukraine der Geschichte
Europas auch den letztlich nicht die
Atomreaktoren selbst sondern nur einen
Ausbildungszentrum auf dem Gelände
getroffen wurde war mehr als deutlich
geworden welches unmittelbare und
gigantische Gefahrenpotenzial
Berlin Atomkraftwerk im Kriegsfall sein
kann und ein ebenso großes wie seit
jeher ungelöstes Problem ist die
Endlagerung des Atommülls ich bin
nicht als ungelöste Frage den nächsten
zukünftigen Generationen zu überlassen
die bundesgesellschaft für endlagerungen
sucht noch immer nach einem geeigneten
Ort um Atommüll für eine Million Jahre
sicher und umweltverträglich zu lagern
als Frist dafür hat man sich zwar 2031
gesetzt aber bereits jetzt ist absehbar
dass das Verfahren aufwendiger ist das
geplant und der Zeitplan kaum
einzuhalten sein wird Finnland ist da
zwei Stück weiter für den strahlenden
Atomen Müll entsteht auf demselben
Gelände das weltweit erste Endlager am
2020 sollen abgebrannte Brennstäbe hier
im 500m tiefen Tunnel ihren Platz finden
aber auch die finden dem Zeitplan
hinterher die Gewichtung all dieser pro
und contra argumente hängt natürlich von
der individuellen Haltung ab und
jedenfalls für mich von den Bedingungen
und dem Kontext der Zeit
ich war ein Leben lang gegen Atomkraft
schlicht weil ich es für
unverantwortlich hielt und halte
unendlichen Generationen nach uns das
ungelöste problemstrahlenden Atommülls
zu hinterlassen Atomkraft war für mich
das Flugzeug das losfliegt ohne das
schon eine Landebahn gebaut werden jetzt
aber ohne russische Energie und mit eh
schon laufenden AKWs Gewichte ich für
mich die Argumente anders finde
zumindest den Weiterbetrieb eh schon
existierender Kraftwerke vertretbar
jedenfalls solange es für die
Energiesicherheit unbedingt nötig ist
Olaf Scholz hat sich im Ampel internen
Streit er macht Wort für ein kurzen
Mittelweg entschieden am 15 April ist
mit den Atomkraftwerken in Deutschland
Schluss und deshalb wird es auch keine
neuen Brennelemente mir geben die
irgendwie für deutsche Kraftwerke
hergestellt werden eine Entscheidung die
einerseits zumindest den diesen Winter
hilft und andererseits den Atomen Berg
nicht weiter vergrößert den schon
produziert zu haben ist schlimm genug
wie stehen sie zur Atomkraft schreiben
Sie es gerne in die Kommentare wollen
Sie auch wissen wieso Gas so teuer
geworden ist dann empfehle ich Ihnen
unsere kontextfolge dazu und wenn Sie
interessiert welche Probleme es bei der
nachhaltigen Stromversorgung gibt dann
schauen Sie sich gerne das Video der
Kollegin und Kollegen von ZDF Info an